when did you really start becoming close
friends with Ian was it immediate yeah
it was pretty immediate Ian and I uh uh
are like we're totally different human
beings I mean like you could not we are
like oil and vinegar in that sense and I
think I think but that that worked well
for us in a yin and yang way it worked
great for our on-screen chemistry it
worked great for sort of having the two
brothers being Polar Opposites yin and
yang energy and we just really kind of
understood immediately that we would
work well together and that we could
create a really good uh dramatic
television series with our different
personalities and I think that lended
itself lends itself to our relationship
off screen which we sort of are very
similar